[Music]
i'm lauren zima here at the race to
erase ms gala at the Beverly Hilton it
was a date night to remember tonight it
is this is the only time we get a date
night I know I wear some nice clothes
and go to a charity event is it the only
time I mean you're that busy I mean at
this point yes I made it yeah it's
definitely been a work here for sure but
you know what I can't complain I got to
tell you as an instinct fan I love how
much you embrace it's gonna be made it's
gonna be made when it is that time for
it's gonna be my does that blow up on
your group text with the guys do you
acknowledge it together you better
believe I mean we've had a group text
for four years and this time of year
it's really funny because you know we
find the best means the most
embarrassing ones of all the other guys
and yeah it's it's fun what are the most
American any picture of me in the 90s
you know they use any pictures I didn't
sink in the 90s it was you know it
wasn't a fun few years for me for any
publicly yeah we were going through our
awkward you know teenage years in front
of the public would you have dated him
back then no I would have done of them
cuz he knows all of us yeah exactly okay
good
[Laughter]